foreign
Space Telescope in the shed which
happens to be here
the James Webb Space Telescope or jwst
we aren't a new back then in the late
80s
80s
90s
the universe was
expressed and we knew that to see the
very first galaxies
and maybe even the first stars that ever
formed in the universe because of the
expansion of the universe the light from
those galaxies is likewise expanded and
it shifted from Blue wavelengths to
longer wavelengths red wavelengths and
so the concept then for the Next
Generation Space Telescope was to build
an advanced telescope that really
focused on the infrared part of the
spectrum because that's where we could
see the first stars in the first
galaxies
I knew that this telescope that was
being built to find to probe the light
from the first galaxies would also be a
fabulous tool to study Neptune and
Uranus I mean I just knew that because I
knew it would be big enough I knew that
because it was a Space Telescope the
images would be stable and pristine and
I knew that these wavelengths of light
in the infrared had all sorts of
interesting molecular signatures so that
we could learn about the upper
atmospheres of these planets and so I'm
like I'm in uh you know I'll do this so
in 2002 I wrote a proposal saying I
would like to be an interdisciplinary
scientist for this program to ensure
that this telescope will be able to do
solar system observations when it is
launched and in 2003 my proposal was
accepted and that how it was how I
formally became involved in this
telescope so web
it's it's different than Hubble it's a
different kind of telescope for a number
of reasons one is it's a lot bigger than
Hubble so it's a six and a half meter
mirror the golden mirror the collecting
area versus Hubble's 2.4
um I mean it's so big that it couldn't
be launched looking like that it had to
be all folded up that's right had to be
folded up and that's why it's the mirror
is segments yeah so that it could be
folded up like a honeycomb like a
honeycomb exactly but then it had to
unfold in space and I I remember how
nervous people were about this process
because it really was something that
everything every single step had to go
right not only did the telescope have to
fold up but we if you look at Webb it's
got this huge Contraption underneath it
which we call a sun shield yeah and
that's crucial for this telescope how
did you feel as you were witnessing the
deployment sequence I sure was nervous
just like everybody else um there were
several single point failures where if
that thing didn't unbolt or unfold we
didn't have a working telescope anymore
yeah yeah so it was extremely
nerve-wracking but we had many years of
testing because we knew that there was
no fixing this telescope this
telescope's not in low earth orbit like
Hubble the James Webb Space Telescope is
a million miles away at a point called
the L2 point and it was put out there
deliberately because it needed to be
cold it needed to have the sun shield to
protect the telescope from the warmth of
the Sun the warmth of the earth and even
the warmth of our moon so the sun shield
is designed to be like a an umbrella
that protects it a sun umbrella that
keeps that telescope super cold so we
couldn't put it in low earth orbit
because it's just too warm in that
environment you can't sense infrared
light when it's hot you have to have it
cold by the way that's also why this
telescope is completely exposed to the
elements of space most other telescopes
have tubes that enclose them and this
one doesn't this the mirrors are just
sitting out they're just out there
they're just sitting out there so the
first Deep Field from jwst I think the
analogy I heard was that the image
itself covers about the amount of space
as a grain of rice on a fingertip held
at arm's length is that right I heard a
grain of sand not a grain of rice okay
but it's the same concept you know uh
that yeah if you the piece of Sky you
see in that picture if you were like
standing in your backyard and looking up
in the sky that piece of sky is about
the same size as a as a tiny grain of
sand if you've moved your grain of sand
over to the left you would see those
more galaxies and over to the left again
more galaxies and anywhere you looked in
the sky it is filled with galaxies
thousands and thousands that one image
alone exactly what I'm waiting for is
the James Webb Space Telescope Deep
Field where we stare for days at a dark
spot that we don't know where anything
is what are we going to see
and then think about that going to be
all over the whole Sky our universe is
gonna mentally expand uh at that moment
when we get that that Deep Field from
James Webb's face telescope it's going
to be it's going to be mind-blowing
I just think about it hearing so far
back in time
to the beginning of you know the
primordial Cosmic Merc yeah when stars
and galaxies are just starting to turn
on and
how different the universe was and the
fact that we humans on this one little
planet Earth can craft an instrument
that has the capability to let us see
that you know 13.5 billion years ago or
whatever it ends up being is is really
phenomenal yeah I
I view it as uh
an example of what Humanity can do when
we work for the greater good you know
when we work as teams and we have a goal
you know this this project required
thousands of people in multiple
countries in multiple states to take
this vision and turn it into a concrete
thing this telescope and then launch it
on a rocket
and then have the ability to use it to
probe you know from from right in our
local neighborhood
all the way to the edge of the known
universe and everything in between yeah
it's amazing to me and everybody had a
role to play I mean the beryllium miners
who mined the beryllium we used to make
the mirrors and the the cable wrappers
who wrapped the cables to allow this
thing to move and the people who you
know built the the different instruments
see we have a suite of four different
instruments cameras and spectrographs
you know both here in Europe you know we
all worked at Canada Canada made the
fine guidance sensor that allows us to
point this thing I mean it's a truly
International effort and it all comes
together
to create this revolution in how we see
the cosmos
do you have a favorite among the images
that have been released so far well they
all have special aspects about them that
make me go wow um in a case of the image
of the the cosmic Cliffs image it's
beautiful it's like blue in the dark and
orange in the bottom and you know I I
get excited about images like that
because not only are they tremendously
beautiful and evocative in a poetic way
but
those are places where
stars are being born yeah and some of
the little Pokey things that that stick
out that give it some of its dramatic
structure you know those are like that's
starbirth in the making and I get I
think that's just so cool and
particularly when we use our infrared
cameras we can look inside some of those
knobs and and see the stars that are
being born and in some places uh just
like the Orion Nebula there was just an
image release to the Orion Nebula that's
places where planetary systems are
forming you know we aren't seeing the
planets but we're seeing the swirling
discs of dust and gas where those
planets are being born and even some of
these galaxy images while they may be
static like the Stefan's quintet image
you know which is five galaxies one of
which is an interloper it's a foreground
Galaxy it's not part of the other crew
just wanted to be in the show yeah it's
just it's just yeah it's just photo
bombing the other ones but the 4 word
that are part of a cluster
what you learn from James Webb Space
Telescope is that in the regions where
they are interacting and overlapping
those regions light up in the infrared
those are places where the dust and the
gas and the existing stars of those
other galaxies when they are interacting
they are forming new stars they are
creating new Realms of star formation
and they just light up in the infrared
in that image so yeah and I just wonder
like what are what's missing from that
picture what is what can jwst fill in I
mean how much more color can it add
um what jwst adds to our ongoing story
is it it adds new wavelengths of light
that we haven't had the sensitivity to
study and different wavelengths of light
tell you different parts of the story
and we also use tools in astronomy
called spectrographs and that is where
we don't just take pictures but we
actually take the light and we spread it
out into its rainbow of colors
and what we do is we look for what we
call fingerprints in that light if you
will certain atoms and molecules tend to
absorb specific colors of light just by
the very nature of their construction
and their motion and vibration they
absorb certain colors of light so by
spreading the light out into a rainbow
and looking for patterns in what light
is missing that tells you what molecules
are there not only does it tell you what
are there it tells you their temperature
it can tell you their pressures by
tracking carefully these lines in the
Spectrum you can determine the Motions
of this material and so we don't just
have a static picture we can actually do
like three-dimensional tomography of
astrophysical objects by using this
spectral light information but as an
astronomer it's not just the picture it
is spreading that light out and looking
into its constituents that's where the
real deep science takes place that's
where you get what are stars actually
made of like helium and the helium and
hydrogen and beryllium and even iron and
nickels how do you know that you can't
go there and weigh it you you learn it
from the light
um can you tell us about that instrument
and what it might be able to show us
about Uranus and Neptune and some of the
other giant planets that we haven't been
able to see before how is this telescope
going to help us understand these worlds
let's say you wanted to study Jupiter's
Rings right we know Jupiter has rings
voyagers saw them but we know most
planetary rings change with time okay
trying to image the faint Ring Of
Jupiter next to the incredibly bright
planet of Jupiter is extraordinarily
difficult the Rings are a million times
fainter than the planet and they're
right next to it
what
James Webb Space Telescope the
sensitivity is so good and the the
Imaging capability is so good that the
scattered light from Jupiter does not
spread even out to the local place where
the Rings are so in our first images
engineering images of Jupiter that were
taken just to test the scattered light
on the scent on the camera they took a
couple of sharp short images of Jupiter
and moved Jupiter closer and closer to
the fighting guidance sensor to see if
it would screw up our guiding even in
those short engineering images
the Rings are right there beautiful just
totally resolved right next to the
planet a million times brighter well can
we talk about planets outside the solar
system too sure yeah what's your
favorite what's what's your favorite oh
I don't know
I got a couple of favorites yeah I think
a lot of astronomers a favorite system
right now is the trappist-1 system yeah
tell me about it yeah Trappist one is um
that's the name of the star well
Trappist is the name of the survey right
but it looked at this star and
um it discovered
um but that there are at least seven
planets orbiting this star
and
most of those planets seem to be
earth-sized
in the trappist-1 system
several of the planets are the right
distance from the host star
that water could be liquid on the
surface something we call that the
habitable zone right and you and I could
have a long talk about what habitability
actual means but you know in our solar
system at least on our Earth the only
place that we know life exists there's a
lot of water yeah and so when we're
talking about looking for habitable
planets we look at planets that are the
right distance from their hosts star
that they could have water on them so
that Trappist system that we know that
there are planets in potentially
habitable region and that those planets
are roughly earth-sized they are
everybody's favorite right now for jwst
to take a look at with our spectrographs
yeah do you think there is life beyond
Earth
somewhere and if so where okay so let me
answer the second question first
um this question of Is there alien life
out there I usually break it up into two
things one is a thought experiment about
the size of the universe the scale of
the universe
just how many stars there are in our
galaxy yeah and then how many galaxies
there's billions of stars just in our
local Galaxy and there's billions of
galaxies out there
and we talk about whether or not life
could have formed
over the billions of years that our our
universe has existed with these billions
of galaxies Each of which it has
billions of stars
I say life has to exist somewhere out
there somewhere has to be out there
does that mean that aliens have come to
Earth and visited us no that's a totally
separate question I just they're not
it's not a related question all right
that's a more psychological question I'm
more interested in the science aspect of
the question I I think we need to start
with terrestrial sized planets that are
the right distance to have water on them
because those are the conditions
required to create Life as we know it on
earth and the only kind of life that
we'll initially recognize is going to be
life like ours I think so jwst is one
tool that we can use in the search for
life beyond Earth but there are others
including within our own solar system
some of the Rovers that are on Mars
currently looking for signs of ancient
biosignatures or ancient signs of alien
life and the Rocks there but also some
of the missions that are being planned
to the outer solar system and
specifically some of the moons there I'm
curious about whether you think it's
possible that life exists here
in our in our local neighborhood but
beyond Earth
hey anything is possible I've learned in
my career never to deal in absolutes
because the universe is great at
throwing curveballs at you
um
you know when we when we have our Rovers
on Mars and our orbiters that are doing
really Exquisite orbital Imaging
um it's clear that there's evidence that
at one time there was liquid water on
the surface of Mars there's you know
there's sedimentation there's a chemical
evidence there's you know actually water
trapped in the ices in the poles of Mars
right now and so uh it it could very
well be that at some time in the past
that planet had liquid water and may
have had the conditions for life to form
we don't know it could be that life
formed there first and transmitted
itself inward to us we could be martial
it could be martial I don't know you
know we don't know the answer to that
um using our definition of looking at
places where there's liquid water
you know people sort of initially
confined it to a certain distance from
the host star you know sort of from the
earth just barely out to Mars and maybe
inward a little bit not quite as inward
as Venus but they kind of limited it to
that region saying well Earth is the
Goldilocks zone that's why it's not too
hot not too cold that's why life is here
but we've learned more about our solar
system with the spacecraft that and and
telescopes
and one of the things that we have
learned with our missions to the Jupiter
system and the Saturn system is that
some of the larger moons in those
systems do have evidence of liquid water
in their Interiors more water on
Jupiter's moon more water inside
Jupiter's moon Europa that we have on
the surface of the Earth which is kind
of crazy think about mind-boggling to
think about yeah
um the question is could life form in
that water and and it gets back to what
are the ingredients you need for life
you need water but you also need some
kind of an energy source you need some
kind of a surface on which life can do
its a chemical thing to form I'm not an
astrobiologist so I don't know what the
right lingo is but you need to have a
surface for stuff to happen
um and does Europa have those things
well it doesn't have them on its surface
its surface is just ice but we know from
our various flybys of this we were able
to map out its its structure its
internal structure by looking at the
magnetic field and how it interacts with
it by looking at gravitational
deflection we know that it probably has
a solid core and we also know that
Europa is warm now why why would this
Moon out there at Jupiter's distance why
would it be warm right why would
Jupiter's other Moon IO have active
volcanoes that's really warm that one
that's crazy warm and the answer is
these moons actually interact with one
another they do like a little resonant
dance with each other as they orbit
Jupiter and as they orbit one another
and interact with one another they their
gravity of these moons makes very tiny
Flexes in the shape of the moons but the
flexes repeat over time and that
repeating warms the planet
um I used to illustrate this for kids
with um like old credit cards if you
ever take an old credit card and you
bend it bend it bend it bend it bend it
and you feel where you're bending it's
warm it gets worse it's really the same
process it's that flexing is what warms
these so for Europa in orbit around
Jupiter we have the water we have the
rocky surface deep inside we have warmth
you know we've got this energy source
thing so is it possible that life is
formed there what man sure
I who am I going to say no I mean what
do I know I mean the universe is much
more complex than I can imagine and
um so we are building a spacecraft
called the Clipper spacecraft which is
going to go to the Jupiter system and do
it's going to orbit Jupiter but it's
going to do multiple flybys of the Moon
Europa so Heidi word on the street is
that you have a favorite Moon
what is it and there's only one right
answer to this question
my favorite moon is Triton
pretty good one it's not the right one
though I was going to say iafedus
that's a long conversation about okay
tell me why Triton is better Triton
Triton is such a cool Moon
it goes in a retrograde orbit backwards
around the planet we think it was
actually a Kuiper Belt object that got
too close to Neptune and was captured by
Neptune and it's a big Moon I mean if
you want Pluto to be a planet I don't
know where you stand on that issue but
Triton is a twin to Pluto all right so
it's like a planet in orbit around
another planet but it's going backwards
but it's going backwards around the
planet and when Voyager flew by in 1989
it actually flew kind of close so we got
a good view of one half of it and it's
got remarkable terrain and it has active
cryo-volcanoes on it there are volcanoes
ice volcanoes erupting on Triton like in
real time so that's pretty amazing I
mean it's got an atmosphere all right
and it could have a liquid water ocean
inside it so it may be an ocean world
and since we know it's active because we
saw it with voyager that may be another
Abode for life so Heidi how did you
become interested in astronomy what was
it that Lit that fire for you it's kind
of a goofy story but I think in one
since I became an astronomer because I
used to get carsick
my family we have family would go on
road trips and um and you know I would
be in the back of the car and I'd be so
sick and I couldn't read I couldn't do
anything except stare out the window and
at night
staring out the window I started to
recognize star patterns like the Big
Dipper and Orion and I became more
familiar with them because that's all I
could do is to stare out at the sky and
so I you know I think that sort of
kindled an interest for me but I had a
math teacher who one day took her class
of four students aside and said where
are you young people planning to go to
college and I when it came to my turn I
said Penn State she said why and I said
well my dad went to Penn State and lived
in Pennsylvania and she said I think you
should apply to MIT wow and I said well
I don't even know what that is so she
she encouraged me and I I applied when
it came time for letters of
recommendation I asked my chemistry
teacher to write me a letter and he said
no
and I said why not he said you'll never
get into MIT
oh I ask my history teacher instead and
she did write a letter and I did get
into MIT and when I brought back my
acceptance letter and showed it to my
chemistry teacher look I got into MIT he
said
it's only because you're a woman they
have quotas to fill
this is a 1978 when people said things
like that to your face
um that made me angry more than anything
so I was determined to go to MIT and
graduate you know what are some of the
most nagging unanswered questions in
your mind that exist in astronomy any
field in astronomy could be anywhere in
the universe close to home far away what
bugs you what keeps you up at night
how did the first stars and galaxies
form in the universe we have lots of
models and theories but to be able to
make actual observations at as early as
we can to tie together some of the
disparate observations we have with a
coherent story I think that is an area
that is very very interesting right now
and of course that's why James Webb
Space Telescope was built to add to a
piece to that story
I think
I'm also interested in how our planetary
system that we live in how did it in
particular come to be and how did it
come to be habitable we know this is the
only one the only system that we know is
inhabited right this our solar system
right is it required that you have giant
planets in the outer system and small
planets in the inner solar system to
make habitability or is it just by
happenstance
did you have to have a Jupiter to make
it habitable did you have to have a
Neptune to sweep out through the Kuiper
belt and deliver volatiles to the inner
solar system water and stuff
I mean I that's so interesting and
um
and it touches us as humans like how did
we come to be it's it's part of our
story it's part of our life story so I'm
very interested in that question as well
and we still have so many observations
left to make both within our solar
system and in the greater Universe I
think astronomers will be busy for a
long time to come